de blasio is at least honest he's an
honest radical and he says
it's more important to participate in
these political ideological activities
than to go to church he's not the only
one
there was there have been a few of these
videos of
what i guess they're calling them
protests but they're not they're really
more
liturgical services one is of a whole
group of white people
kneeling down and begging forgiveness
of a whole group of black people
standing up take a listen
this is in some backyard somewhere i
guess
probably i don't know how many 60 70
white people kneeling down
to maybe i don't know 40 50 black people
standing up
it's kind of hard to make out what he's
saying particularly as i'm talking over
him but
even you're listening to it normally you
can't hear it that well
just to watch it there
is no difference between this and a
religious liturgical ritual
right i'm catholic i go to mass mass has
lots of rituals lots of kneeling and
lots of smells and bells
lots of things that we all do together
if i were to i mean they
they obviously look different in in
terms of you know it's not a bunch of
like liberals wearing t-shirts you know
looking like ruffians
but to actually look at the movements up
and down they are
identically liturgical same thing there
was another protest i don't know where
it was
it was just a whole huge group probably
over a hundred white people
with their hands up sitting on the
ground chanting
mantras that are being given to them by
the leader of the liberal liturgy
about racism anti-blackness or violence
i will use my voice in the most
uplifting way possible
i will love my black neighbors the same
as my white ones
get kind of cult vibes here don't you
that's what my friend tyler cardin over
the blaze tweeted out he said is this a
cult
i think this is a cult it just reminds
you you go to church and you say maya
culpa maya culpa man moxie mcculpe
through my fault through my fault for my
most grievous fault
or when you recite things lord have
mercy lord have mercy right
that is it is a liturgy but it's a
liturgy of this weird religion called
liberalism
[Music]
[Music]
you